and i got about twelve thousand dollars
in mowers so i'm about
fifty two thousand in debt okay but you
have a hundred thousand dollars sitting
in cash in the bank
yeah over i have about 120.
okay 120 000 saved and you've got about
fifty two thousand dollars in debt what
do you say you become debt free before
we start tackling this house
yeah you know i thought about that i
really did it's just the mower's your
interest
you know so
you're running to get rid of my cash
i i get that
you are running a
high um
a high liability business
you are
going to enter into a season um in the
winter where it may not rain as much it
may may not be as much mowing or it
takes one month of low rain to affect
this and then there can be one market
downturn and suddenly you're
000 as a real estate guy um turns into
way less than that
and so
you don't need to be saving for a house
on one end and trying to scrounge up
one percent or two percent interest
somewhere and at the same time pan out
on
um
your subaru and i know it feels good to
have zero percent on your mowers man but
they're still a liability they're
depreciating asset liability against
your business you're going to have to
replace them you have to upkeep right so
pay all that crap off be debt free today
and then you got fifty thousand dollars
and the way you work and as hard as you
work man hopefully you will be able to
scratch that back together here soon
nathan what's the payment on the subaru
every month
670. nathan
you're too smart to pay 670 dollars
a month to a car dealership oh yeah i
know i only put like
3 000 down don't tell me that because i
was just going to say how smart and why
i know we were about to compliment you
nathan and here's the thing you are
going to win with money but you need to
draw a line in the sand where you say
you know what i'm just not going to be
the type of guy who has payments
that's it and once you draw that line
you are going to be so incredibly
wealthy because every single dollar you
have coming in and you are really good
at bringing those dollars in aren't you
it's going to stay with you which means
you're going to save up for that house
so much faster you're gonna feel the
progress
instead of giving seven eight nine
hundred dollars away to lenders every
month because you're pumped on zero
percent interest
i want you to become the bank nathan and
you can do that but i want you to pay
off this debt you're gonna have almost
70k left over to start getting this
house and if you want to get a 15-year
mortgage that's fine but clearly you
want to pay for this thing in cash and
you're not going to get there with
payments in your life
here's the deal if you want to save up
money if you're going to be bringing in
if you if you think you're going to keep
crushing it that way i know how your
mind works and you are always looking
for the next dollar and the way to
maximize this and to leverage that
against that take that money and stick
it in the money market account
and let it sit this isn't about
growth money this is about buying a
house money if it's gonna sit for two or
three years put it in a money market
account it's way way way less volatile
it's gonna be safe there and it's just
gonna be waiting for you when you're
ready to buy that house right yeah
nathan i'd park that uh at a money
market or a high yield savings account
online if you wanna do that you're gonna
get about a half a percent right now
which is boring right but you know
what's not going to happen it's not
going to disappear because you wanted to
invest in dogecoin because you could
double your money next month right so
nathan you're a hard-working guy we're
rooting for you i just want you to be
debt-free today and when you have money
in the bank like that john i'm like what
do you make the call right now get off
the phone with us and go pay off this
debt be debt-free today and again it's
so hard when you're a hard charger and
you're a maximizer i'm gonna move this
to this and that's zero percent i can
balance that
it feels like you're winning and like
you said at the end of the day 900
a month are leaking out the back door to
pay for mowers all depreciating assets
right yep and for you're making subaru
rich you're making john deere rich
you're making home depot rich make
nathan rich nathan rich nathan rich i
love this i'm gonna get that on a
t-shirt make nathan rich be debt-free
before the day is over brother nathan i
want nathan to pay for those t-shirts
though he's got money he can afford it
send them to us nathan we're not paying
you back either i love it we got more
the ramsay show coming up stick around
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
i'm george campbell i'm joined by dr
john dolone this hour
open phones triple eight eight two five
five two two five give us a call we'd be
happy to help you we'd be happy to to
yell at you
uh we'd be happy to give you a hug
whatever you need whatever they need you
can't hug anymore that's true i'm not
really a yeller
occasionally you know me john i'm so
aggressive no it sounds like a little
dog barking when i yell it's very
different like a shih tzu like
exactly or like my french bulldog which
i know you love we got through almost
two whole segments before you mention
that dog someone's having a drinking
game at home seeing how long i'll go
without mentioning my i hope they're not
because they're gonna need liver
replacement
all right let's go to the phones we've
got armin in los angeles arm and welcome
to the ramsay show
hey guys how's it going great how are
you
pretty good uh so i just had a quick
question uh before i get into the
question let me get some uh backstory uh
so i'm 18 years old i got a part-time
job and i also balance that job with
studies at university
uh the only form of liabilities that i
have is a lease payment of 250 dollars a
month
and the auto insurance is paid for by my
father
so i kind of wanted to ask with the
part-time job that i have i bring in
about a thousand dollars a month so i
wanted to ask how do i because i also
wanted to incorporate the every dollar
budget and just kind of follow it and i
was wondering
is the emergency fund separate from the
savings um and the investment so say
um is the emergency fund itself the
savings or is it separate from the
savings so like every month i would need
to put aside money for
investments savings and emergency funds
or would the emergency fund already be
the savings and then um also another
thing
as of right now i have about seven
thousand five hundred dollars saved up
um and my tuition expenses are covered
by the university financial aid
um so i'm just wondering bringing in
about thousand dollars a month uh 7 500
saved up right now um
how much should i be setting aside for
um the every dollar uh budget app
how old are you man
um i'm 18.
where did you where did you
learn to work so hard and to
have such a vision for what tomorrow
might look like
um
i mean honestly i i like to think that
uh i mean in this world that we live in
universities say like degrees and
whatnot but although they are losing
their value
um i still want to hustle on the side
because i i'm aware of the fact that my
although i'm pursuing my studies i'm not
doing it for the degree rather um
because i enjoy the studies themselves
philosophy yeah yeah
did you did you did your parents teach
you this or did you just make a decision
one day that i'm going to be a guy that
hustles and grinds and gets it done
what is i'm telling you you're a really
impressive 18 year old you're asking
some sophisticated questions that
millions of 50 and 60 year olds in this
country have never asked and so it's
impressive it's really really impressive
and so if your old man and your mom
taught you this stuff kudos to them if
you saw the way that they had done life
and decided you're gonna do it
differently kudos to everybody man and
kudos to you but good for you man yeah
that's awesome uh so let's talk the
money side here you've got a thousand
dollars coming in every month and you
have 7 500 saved and you raised a great
question the emergency fund is separate
from savings the answer is yes your
emergency fund is for you guessed it
emergency so i don't want you touching
that unless you have a legitimate
emergency of a flat tire there's a
medical issue your savings are going to
be for your other goals right so if you
want to save up and pay cash for a car
you want to save up for a down payment
and then your investing is going to be
separate
and we teach a process around here
called the baby steps and so we teach to
have a thousand dollar starter emergency
fund in baby step one baby step two
we're gonna pay off all of our debt from
smallest to largest using the debt
snowball regardless of the interest rate
and that's everything but the house then
we're going to focus on a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses which right now i doubt you
have a lot right if you have a thousand
dollars coming in every month and you're
doing all right
and so you probably
right now have you probably could be a
baby step three my concern here is the
lease you have a leased car that has 200
15 month payment is that right yeah so i
i guess some backstory on that so i i
really wanted to get like a used vehicle
2014 but my dad is very traditional so
he kind of and one day i came out of
work and he impulsively had about the
car the leased car
uh so i was kind of stuck with the car
i'm like well
that now i guess my dad went and
impulsively bought the lease so now i'm
kind of stuck like i don't know if i
should be he impulsively got a lease car
for you
in your name yeah it's in his name not
under my name no in in his name but he
he wanted it for me so you thought i
would be excited such an inspiring gift
that he got something that you have to
pay for every month
exactly
that's true love right there so um what
would it look like for your relationship
if you said dad i'm going to be debt
free i've got 7 500 bucks i have a
thousand dollar emergency fund i'm going
to go buy a 3 500 honda accord or a
camry that's going to get me to and from
school
and i would like to no longer be paying
on this lease
uh
the relationship would be
not hard to maintain but there will
definitely be some some uh i guess
difficulties trying to explain that to
him because he's a very traditional man
that's cool i get that and you're doing
something that's very untraditional
which is taking ownership of your life
and your money right
yeah yeah um and i got one quick
question before i turn back over to
george you say everything's covered by a
financial aid office are you taking out
a bunch of student loans or are you
being paid for the pell grants and
grants and other types of scholarships
you know everything that is provided for
my tuition is that free it's grants and
scholarships yeah and i'm i'm fully yeah
i i i despise that so once my dad got
the car i was in shock yeah so yeah
what's the terms of this lease how much
longer is it
uh so it's three years and i guess the
in not really enticing part but but one
thing that kind of uh
didn't make this situation seem so bad
is my dad offered to um cover um all of
the insurance so the lease is actually
320 but my dad
my dad is uh willing to pay some portion
of that and only i pay 250 dollars lease
um so he's
trying to make this situation listen to
what you just said though
this not so bad
my dad's gonna pay a hundred of this and
i only have to pay 250 of a thing that i
didn't even want or ask for
and i know that you're doing your best
to rationalize the gift that you give
and i know that car is nicer than
whatever but you are in a messy
situation here
back to your question about budgeting
armin uh one if we can get rid of this
debt maybe you find out the payoff
amount maybe you talk to your dad and
figure out a situation to get this car
out of your life i drive a car that cost
me six thousand dollars it's the nicest
car i've ever driven
and in your situation you're doing great
so far and if you can get through
college debt-free i don't want you
concerned about you know making some
crazy investments right now i want i'm
more concerned about investing in
yourself as you get through college and
if you can save up a pile of money when
you graduate and you're debt-free man
you're going to be so far ahead of
almost every american
so that's what i want for you and part
of that is getting rid of this debt part
of that is having that emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses right
now you don't have many but once you
graduate you may get your own place and
you're gonna have a job you're gonna be
making a lot more than a thousand
dollars a month and you're gonna have to
have these habits in place and so i love
that you're thinking about how do i
budget and balance this all right now
and the key here is we want to list out
all of your expenses and make sure that
your income minus your expenses equal
zero
and if you get rid of that lease
you just got a 250 raise every single
month until you graduate that you can
sock away into savings for whatever that
next goal is maybe it is to pay cash and
upgrade the car if you get a car once
you get rid of this lease maybe it you
want to put a down payment on a house
and i see your calling from the la area
that's gonna take a lot more money than
it would in idaho and so you're gonna
have to make some big strides here
financially once you graduate and you
can do that but i want you to do it
debt-free and i want you to do it uh
through the baby steps and there is this
illusion you just mentioned it so if
we're throwing dollars amount i think i
bought my
car that i drive right now for fourteen
thousand dollars because i'm a i'm a
baller
baller the the car that got me through
college was a thousand dollars right for
four years you there's this illusion
that to be safe you have to get a brand
new car or a lease or when you make this
much money you have to have a car that's
like this when you get this job you have
to have this car you just don't yeah
it's not bad to have a great car man if
you can go in there and write a check
for it it's incredible and it's awesome
and wonderful the same way my dad wanted
me to have a safe reliable new car
that's right right it's being a good dab
but being a good dad also means not
putting your kid into debt we're
cheering you on army you got this man
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i'm george campbell by my side is dr
john dolone ramsey personality and on
the line is mary in denver colorado mary
i see on my screen you are debt free
yeah that's it that's me
congratulations
we love to hear it okay how much have
you paid off
okay now 21 000.
[Music]
you broke up honestly
try talking directly into your phone
there
41
hundred forty one dollars in eighteen
months
wow
and how long did this take 18 18 months
um
and what was your range of income during
that time
um it was and it started at 85 000 and
went up to 95 000. 85 to 95 way to go
for a living
um i work at management
and what kind of management
uh property management property
management outstanding awesome so what
kind of debt was this
uh you know what it was all consumer
debt so um i did and i didn't learn this
until i did financial piece but um i had
credit card debt i got a consolidation
loan
and it did what the class taught is it
doubled the debt that i had so that's
how it got up that high yeah so this was
all credit cards
um yeah
mary what were you buying i'm really
intrigued this must have been a fun ride
it was fun oh my gosh i had so much fun
computer
car repairs i did a road trip um saw my
credit card without like knowing or
knowledge of you know how to uh you know
how to manage a budget or anything so
you're having the time of your life
living off of credit cards what happened
18 months ago where you said all right
the ride's over
um so
it was kind of about the early 2020 and
i started to really get nervous just
watching the news and seeing everything
going on
and so
i was googling on my phone like how to
get out of debt um and i remember i was
like up all night i found financial
peace i did the free trial and i think i
binged
three episodes like that first night
um and then i like that opened up the
whole world for me um and yeah that's
just how i got started wow you seem like
whatever you do you just go all in if
you want to have some fun you're all in
on some fun you're 42 000 in and then
you decide you know what i need i need
to get out of this thing what was that
shift in your heart that changed where
you said i don't want to live like this
anymore
um it definitely um was first like a
wake-up call like i think taking that
accountability
um so one of the things that really
stood out to me was just the ability to
be able to walk away like walk away from
like a toxic job or walk away from
you know you know just having that
empowerment was really big for me um
and then another part was like kind of
letting go of the shame of it because
for so long i kept it a secret i kept it
a secret from my family my friends like
nobody knew that i had this huge burden
i was carrying around
um so coming to that community was huge
for me how did you
how did you free yourself from that
because shame is one of those
powerful restrictive agents that keeps
us in the dark and holding onto secrets
and just collapses our spirits and our
physical bodies and our mental our
mental health how did you
let that go
um i told somebody so
well the first person i talked to is
actually like a preferred ramsay coach i
like put a question in was so surprised
when someone reached out to me and i had
a phone call um and then the second one
was my sister like i just trust my
sister so much and um i told her on the
phone i was like what is this is how
much that i'm carrying around with me
and like she just had no idea and i
think it was first just being vulnerable
and telling somebody that's really what
helped me to start letting go of it
that's the magic when it comes to shame
is putting the secret out in the open
right and
being heard being vulnerable for that
first time did your sister respond to
you with you idiot i hate you and i wish
you were never my sister
no not at all she was like i'm here i'll
be she's my accountability partner she's
like i'm here for you
call me if you have questions
you know support or whatever and i like
celebrated all my wins with her so that
was really good i love that i love to
hear it so what was the key for you mary
what was the key to getting out of debt
um the budget like it sounds so simple
but it's so true and it really didn't
make sense to me until i did the classes
and then i used the uh every dollar app
and it just clicked for me and it's just
it's just like it seems like magic kind
of it just works so well for me
um
just using a budget that's that's the
key
i love it how old are you mary
i am 31. wow 31. you used a word that's
somewhat of a swear word among
25 to 30 year olds and the word you used
was accountability what's something you
would tell to
25 to 30 year olds across the country
and by the way just between you and me
to the 45 and 55 and 65 year olds across
the country
how do you how do you
come to a reckoning with accountability
when you have to look mary in the mirror
and say enough's enough
um it was kind of like
you know um
you made this mess and the only way
you're going to get out is that you get
yourself out of it what you should run
for congress run for congress people
this smart don't run for
it
congress
oh mary we need more mary's in the world
good for you this is awesome how does it
feel to be debt free
it's so cool it's awesome it's fun
like i have like all the money coming in
i'm on baby step three is like mine and
like i just gotta transfer that over to
savings that's so cool because
like when i was budgeting one paycheck
you know was like all to debt and now
that paycheck is like mine so it feels
awesome yeah it's a lot more fun when
you do it on your terms and you're the
bank and you don't have to make payments
on the fun once you get home
right yeah
it's not true and i see you like to
travel on my screen i see pictures of
you traveling and you've got dogs it
seems like you just want to live life to
the fullest and you can do that even
more full with no payments right
yeah
like i said one of my favorite trips it
was awesome but that was the one i found
the credit cards but now when i travel i
don't have to be guilty or i feel like i
have a plan i'll feel in control
wow yeah i'm excited but mary you're
losing out on all the travel points oh
my gosh how are you going to pay for
vacations now
i you know i stayed about 400 it's so
much better that way i didn't know you
could do that mary you're weird mary
you're weird well we're so proud of you
mayor we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that's absolutely the
next step in your story and you're 31
years old you are going to leave a
legacy you can be so outrageously
generous for the rest of your life
because you don't have payments and you
get to call the shots we also got a copy
of the total money makeover for you to
pay it forward give it to a friend who's
having some fun right now racking up 42
000 in credit card debt and maybe they
can be where you are 18 months from now
how's that sound awesome that's so
awesome thank you all right well let's
get to it we've got mary from denver
colorado
41 841 dollars paid off in 18 months
making 85 up to 95 thousand dollars
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
okay three two one i'm down
[Music]
[Applause]
way to go mary
that's how it's done john
i i i almost felt you raising the roof
next to me i haven't felt the roof
racing i wanted to raise it i'm not tall
enough to raise any roof at this point i
appreciate you giving it a shot roof
razor that was incredible
there's so much in there that i mean we
could unpack that on the play-by-play
for days john but i'm just so pumped to
hear from people like mary people who
are my age going you know what there's
another way yeah it doesn't have to be
this way and this idea of looking in the
mirror and saying i have a mess i have
to say that out loud i've got to call
someone that i love and say i've really
screwed up and i made a mess and i'm
gonna have to get myself out of this and
i hope you'll walk alongside me and most
of the time the people we love will
right and then you take responsibility
and you just get after it yep it's hard
to look in the mirror but i think a lot
of people had to do this especially in
the last 18 months with this pandemic
they can't not look at the mirror and
they're looking at this house of cards
that they've built where everything's
built on payments and if one thing falls
apart their life is destroyed yeah it's
built on comfort and
um
what's gonna make me feel good right now
right now and tomorrow
and the bill will be that's that's
that's uh that's the next month problem
yeah that's october's next month me gets
to deal with that that's exactly right
this month me gets to
eat a fancy burrito and some avocado
toast or whatever that's what it's all
about well i love seeing young people
get a hold of this stuff take
accountability and take personal
responsibility for their lives and
realize that they are in control that's
what this whole show is all about is
getting back to control
you can do this you can be the next mary
to call in and let us know you are debt
free this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window covering you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more you can use promo
code ramsey to get the best deal today's
question comes from sandra in virginia
my husband and i have been married seven
years and this is the second marriage
for both of us
when we first got married he was in
several fantasy football leagues and did
not work full-time he's been working
full-time for four years now and he's
cut back to one fantasy football league
he's cut back he's got back that's a
great language i have no issue with
watching games however the 15 plus hours
a week that goes into following pro
football is a bit much
growing up my father frequently bet on
horse races losing quite a bit of money
and time to this addiction
because of this i'm very much against
gambling as i've seen it destroy people
and families could you please set the
record straight regarding if buying into
brackets and or fantasy football is a
wise financial slash life choice oh
sandra sandra
um
i've got a bunch of friends in my life
there like your husband
oh man so we can answer your money
question here this is very much not a
money question
um
this is a conversation that y'all two
need to sit down and have on a couple of
different levels one level being
regardless of what the
the issue is fantasy football watching
football cooking i want to go back to
school i want to quit my job and start a
calligraphy business whatever it is
something is setting off an alarm system
that you have it's been there since you
were a little girl because of some
behaviors that your dad did
and the old you marry your unfinished
business is often true um really often
true
and you've married your unfinished
business and now you've got alarms
setting off because your husband reminds
you a lot like your dad and you've lived
in the aftermath right you've had to
live in the ashes of the life that
you're dead gambling and destroying
families destroying people being
addicted losing a lot of money all those
things
and so number one you have to recognize
you are you're dragging your past here
your body's responding to stuff in the
present that happened in the past and
you got to be honest with yourself about
it and more importantly you got to be
honest with your husband about it
and that is number two which is your
husband's hiding and running from
something he is living an alt-life they
call it fantasy
right just because it doesn't have elves
and
mushrooms and dragons flying around
using other grown men as pawn pieces
instead of being married i'm not against
fantasy football that's what you want to
do rock it on but living in that world
instead of living in the real world
which is your wife and your kids in your
home
is a problem it's a distraction it's an
addiction it is numbing out it's
disappearing right so there needs to be
some sort of conversation where both of
y'all get away from this not in a fight
don't bring the stuff up when you're
already upset but getting away and
saying hey
what's the what is the picture of our
marriage what is our vision for this
thing going to look like because right
now i'm losing
a lot of hours to you to
pretending you are a coach of pretend
teams using real other grown men as the
player pieces right
and so
i think y'all got to get away and have
some hard hard scary conversations about
what
connection looks like for you what a
relationship looks like for you
what
football versus hiding versus
entertaining versus running what that
looks like you'll need to have a hard
hard conversation and george when it
comes to
is buying into brackets or fantasy
football a why is life financial choice
i don't like to look at it like that as
much as it's a hobby it's entertainment
yeah it's a game right so if you're
gonna put money aside for going to the
movies or going out to dinner it's it
goes in that category yeah until it
becomes
i got four leagues and i don't see my
kids i don't hang out with my wife
because i'm in the basement it's a
part-time job that's exactly right and
so that that's what worries me the most
uh even more than any money spent here i
don't know if it's hundreds or thousands
of dollars i mean we have some people
around the office they like to do a
bracket it's fun they throw in 25 bucks
and it's just a fun thing and to me i'm
like okay that's great if you can budget
for that and you're debt free and this
is fun money coming out of your
entertainment part of your budget that's
okay i don't know that he can get there
right now if he can just leapfrog to
that point because this does feel like
addiction level
um and i i would question is the
priority here in marriage or fantasy
football and at 15 hours a week i don't
know that he's seeing much of his wife
if he's working full-time right
and so no there's nothing wrong with
fantasy football and yeah it can be a
really dumb financial choice if you're
sinking money and time into this thing
that could be better spent elsewhere i'm
sure you guys have other financial
priorities uh over you know using pawns
in a football scheme with you know 25
year old dudes i mean it just feels like
there should be more to life than this
and i i'm not against sports right
people spend a lot of money on sports
and going to games and season tickets
and all that stuff's fun but not when it
takes over your marriage right and i'm
i'm a man i'm a
i'll be the first guy i'm one of the
loudest voices in the country about
especially with men need to get together
and hang out with friends and be
together with friends in reality if well
if fantasy football binds you together
great man have some guys but y'all get
together once a week right you get
together and
finishing football is awesome for some
really remarkable long uh
text message threads where everybody's
talking trash and everyone's you know
bringing up all the high school stuff
everyone's getting into it with each
other that's a blast
when you are spending 15 hours
20 hours a week researching and studying
and trying to get the insides and on the
sub sub subreddit
yeah and your wife is sitting there
saying
what about me yeah yeah that's a
relationship problem that's tough all
right let's go to the phone lines we're
headed to phoenix arizona tristan is on
the line tristan welcome to the ramsay
show
hello gentlemen how are you doing today
doing great how can we help
yes sir uh i have a question uh
concerning my debt
um i'm currently in the air force i've
been serving for about three years thank
you so much thank you so much for that
well thank you for your support
definitely means a lot um so my question
like i said pertains to my debt and i
currently want to know the best process
of
essentially getting out of my debt
i've actually been in debt for
since i was 16 uh to my own account i
was a binge spender in high school hey
brother hey we're coming up against the
clock so let's get right to your
question man um yes there is a big
spender and you got a lot of debt
yes sir so my question is um i have 25
000 in debt
with my truck and i my grandfather's 6
100
how much do you want to help me get out
of my debt
uh i make currently
28 000 a year
you have any savings anything in cash
uh
no sir it's pretty much all been going
to my truck debt
is uh is your truck
yeah you got to sell the truck brother
yes sell the truck asap what do you what
do you what is it worth
uh it's worth twenty thousand yeah the
value definitely is under sell it sell
it by this weekend and take that five
thousand bucks uh i'm sorry you're gonna
take out a loan for that five thousand
dollars and then you're gonna get a
thousand bucks on top of that and you're
gonna go get the smallest
junkiest but safest to and from car
and then you're gonna be out of this
you're gonna be down to eleven thousand
so right now what you owe
what uh
31 thousand dollars right you'll be down
to 11 yeah by by monday i know that's
hard to hear tristan but you're you're
in a really tough financial spot there's
not a lot coming in i would also see if
we can get that income up at 28 000 it's
gonna be hard to make progress on any of
this i mean your truck is worth about
what you make in a year and so that
frightens me and so i'd go to uh check
around do your due diligence and
research go to you know vroom.com and
carvana and carmax and local dealerships
and see who's going to give you the best
offer for this truck so you can be as
little underwater as possible and to
cover the difference like john's saying
you can go to your local credit union
and take out a small loan to cover that
difference so that you can get out of
this underwater truck and then we can
deal with paying off grandpa but we got
to get a thousand dollar emergency fund
here because you're going to keep
staying in the cycle if you don't get
out of this thing and have a buffer
between you and life you're just running
up against it every every time tristan
are you living on base
i i just actually moved off of base um
currently i can't live on base because
it would actually take more from me than
give away okay does your housing
allowance cover your your room and board
yes sir it does okay good so this 28 000
is just paying for your internet and
your
food and your car right
correct okay cool yeah dude you're going
to be that guy rolling up to to work at
the air force in a crummy old car but
that's what it's going to take for you
to turn this thing around and change a
lifetime of bad behaviors and then
create something new for yourself my man
absolutely tristan we're rooting for you
man you can use the dead snowball to get
out of this thing that is what we teach
you can google and find out all kinds of
things about that but you got this man
hey it's been a fun hour john we've got
two more few more to go
thank you for agreeing with me i want to
thank producer james childs associate
producer and phone square screener kelly
daniel we'll be back this is the ramsay
show
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsay
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm george campbell and i'm joined
today by ramsay personality dr john
deloney host of the dr john baloney show
best-selling author he's a dad he's a
father
a friend to many john good to have you i
think i'm a friend to about four i'm
your i used to be friends with james and
i think he broke up with me yesterday
it's hard when it's your producer i got
a different relationship he said we used
to be friends and co-workers we're just
not cool james never text you let's be
honest that is true all right well hey
that's a free call triple eight eight
two five five two two five we can talk
money life relationships mental health
anxiety what you're stressed about what
you're excited about we are happy to to
take really any calls on this friday
we're having a good time that's right
let's do this we've got kyle in
philadelphia pennsylvania kyle welcome
to the ramsay show
hey guys how's it going great how can we
help
um yeah so i actually just had a
question of i'm fairly new to the whole
uh
that snowball method and everything like
that welcome to the crazy gang brother
yeah i know right
um so i kind of just had a question of
how i should get started um i guess a
little back story is i
um recently just purchased a
new car uh well fairly new car
2017
mazda
back in january of 2020
uh right before everything happened of
course but uh so i was actually living
with parents my rent was like 250
um but
then i got kicked out so uh why'd they
kick you out
uh just bad relationship with step mom
what'd you do kyle
nothing to do
what'd you do you're on the radio
it was just arguments all the time i
wasn't the nicest person
um
so now that i'm paying rent um honestly
the second biggest expense i have is my
car
and i'm in a unique situation where my
car
is valued at what i owe
the problem is
is i've been doing the debt snowball so
i don't have any leftover money i'm on
baby step two so i already have a
thousand dollar emergency fund
everything else i had i dumped into debt
so i'm trying to figure out how to like
if i should sell my car and then
um
like pretty much save up money
to be able to buy a new car then sell my
car
or like that's what i'm calling you guys
i'm kind of just trying to figure out my
situation the best route for me what do
you owe
so i owe 12.5 and my car value is
is higher than 12.5 but i have
i was involved in a hit and run so
with the damage my car is valued at 12.5
okay and is that your only debt
no i have credit card debt uh pretty
much everything together by about
uh i got maybe like
just under five grand of credit card
debt okay and what do you mean five
uh so i make about no i'm bad at math i
would say maybe
38 thousand
maybe 39 you can be really bad at math
but you know your salary
yeah true
um so i think what do you do
i work in a financial institution you're
a financial advisor and you don't know
how much money you make he never said he
was an advisor what do you do i wasn't
an advisor i'm a banker ah see the
opposite side you're a banker that
doesn't know how much money he makes
you are you are
you're reinstilling confidence in
america don't name the bank i don't know
that people are going to want to go
there
okay well let's help kyle out let's help
let's help this guy out so you've got a
thousand dollar emergency fund and
you're saying if i can sell the car i'll
be kind of at zero with the car i'll
zero out that debt i'll still have five
thousand in credit card debt right
correct okay and you then you still need
a car exactly i still need a car that's
my problem yeah how quickly could you
save up
four thousand dollars three thousand
dollars to go get a cheap car
yeah that's and that's the second
biggest issue is i saw i just said i'd
make like twenty 2400 a month uh i have
about two grand with the bills um
so how are the bills two grand
just everything all together i mean i'm
i'm i'm also explaining like
i put in my gas my groceries okay you're
saying your total expenses are two grand
yeah everything every month
two grand
okay and you're saying you have four
hundred dollars left to throw at the
dead snowball
pretty much uh sometimes a little less
if i you know work less hours or
anything like that but can you can you
work
more hours can you pick up side jobs
so the problem is my family it's really
weird but the bank i work at doesn't
allow us to have a second job i don't
know
why kyle that's not even a kyle that's
not even a thing i've never heard of
that i can't tell you what you can do
off hours you can go drive uber you can
go work at starbucks or mcdonald's
mcdonald's is paying like 111 an hour
now because there's no workers they're
desperate you can go stock shelves at a
grocery store
and you're making
like you're making 38 000 a year you're
not making a million and so if they're
gonna cap you at under 40 grand a year
and not let you get other work you need
to go find another job today
here's what i'm hearing i'm hearing a
dude who is pretty smart
who's got an attitude problem and who
thinks he's got stuff figured out and he
wants to change stuff but not really am
i fair
yeah
yeah
here's what we do on this show we love
you
and we tell the truth to you okay
is that cool
that works here's
brother you're a banker you're smart i
know you are in your hustle are you a
hustler
yes i believe i am i agree with you okay
so by the time this weekend is over that
car is sold and you've bought a thousand
dollar hunk of junk that's going to get
you to and fro
and no one's going to want to date you
you're not going to want to be seen and
i don't care because you're broke you're
a broke banker my brother right yes i am
and you're going to write your mom your
stepmom a letter and say i'm sorry for
being a jerk and i'm working on it and
then you're going to get a second and a
third job and you're not going to go
inside of a restaurant you're not going
to go to a movie you're not going to go
on a date you're going to get this crap
paid off asap
and that's the kind of intensity and
that's the kind of swagger you're going
to have to have to get this stuff
knocked out and you have to say never
ever again kyle how old are you
25
what do you want to be doing at 30 what
kind of life do you want to have
i want to be debt free definitely
no that's my main problem that's like
that's like six months from now what do
you want to do in five years
um
that's a question i still haven't
figured out yet
i kind of want to be a teacher i'll be
honest with you but then and i go with
student loan debt that's my big problem
there too you don't have to do it you
already capping yourself brother you're
like hey i really want to do this thing
but i can't
i've already got a car but i just i'm
hearing a lot of well my situation is
unique and what you got to understand is
and i'm hearing a lot of excuses
kyle go get it brother
i think you need you need to get some
mojo and you need to go get the second
and third job you need to clean up your
life you need to follow the baby steps
get rid of the credit card debt sell the
car get as much money as you can for it
go to you know vroom and carvana and
carmax and every site on the planet to
see if you can maybe make some money off
this thing to then pay for that car in
cash and then go to night school and
take a couple of classes a semester
towards your dream of becoming a teacher
which is an extraordinary profession my
whole family is a made up of teachers
and be a part of changing the next
generation of folks they don't have to
live the life that you're living right
now
but man already coming up with a dream
and an excuse and a dream excuse kyle
today you're 25. today it stops today
you paid us nothing and your life's
gonna be different the air is gonna
taste a little sweeter tomorrow because
you're gonna make some major major
changes starting with number one sell
your stupid car there it is this is the
ramsey show
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it is a real estate gold rush out there
if you've been paying attention to the
real estate market you've noticed that
competit competition between buyers out
there is intense in part because the
inventory of available housing has been
hitting all-time lows now when the
inventory is low it simply means there
are more buyers buying than sellers
selling and that turns up the pressure
on everyone and buyers want to snag the
right house sellers want to accept the
right offer but this is an amateur hour
low inventory is here to stay so to win
in this market you need a pro by your
side that's why we find vet and endorse
top real estate agents across the
country called endorsed local providers
to help you buy or sell our agents have
years of industry success and refuse to
compromise your financial goals no
matter how tough the competition is and
the good news is you can instantly
connect with an endorsed local provider
in your area today all you have to do is
go to ramseysolutions.com
agent to find a ramsay trusted agent
near you that's ramsay solutions.com
agent we've got bianca on the phone in
trenton new jersey bianca welcome to the
ramsay show how can john and i help
hi so um since the potemk started um
my student loans have differed
so in february i'll start paying them
again my question is would it be best to
pay the student loan in full
um they're undefeated once it um opens
up again or shy pay like let's say half
the student loan and then wait a couple
months
save um some more money and then pay
like the rest all are you saying you
have the cash to pay it off
yes uh by february i will have the cash
to pay at all yes and i already paid off
i think
31 grand of my
51 grand
that's awesome well hey if you were in
prison today and i said hey you could
get out today or you could get out in
four months which one would you take
um
i would say if i had to cash on me i
would say today
only i only need a couple more grand
to have it all that's wonderful as soon
as you have that money pay it off
there's nothing to wait for you don't
have to wait to wait for the deferment
to stop until february 1st when people
start making their payments again you
can pay it as soon as you have the money
so let me make sure that we've got your
financial picture straight here do you
have any other debt
i do have a car loan um
which is um
18 grand which i am paying every single
month so that is no problem there and
um i was going to focus on doing that
one next after my student loan is paid
off you have 31 000 in student loans
i have 21 now i did pay off 31
a couple months ago okay well what we
teach around here is the baby steps and
so that starts with a thousand dollar
emergency fund do you have a thousand
dollars currently yes i do okay so then
baby step two what we're gonna do is
attack the smallest debt so we're paying
minimum payments on everything but that
smallest debt we are attacking with a
vengeance so you're saying you have two
debts right now you have 21k in student
loan debt 18k in car debt yeah okay so i
want you attacking that car debt first
because you're gonna feel the progress i
mean you could i'm guessing you could
pay that car off today
um
i'll need yeah a couple more on that so
it's either like the student loan first
or the car first so i'll just need like
a couple more grand to do either or
yeah i would get rid of that car first
if i were you uh i'm guessing that car
has a interest rate on there do you know
what that is
um it's a 3.5 interest rate yeah so
i mean the car debt is lower so that's
already going to the debt snowball but
you're paying interest on this car and
you're not paying interest on the
student loans right now so i would get
rid of that car as soon as you can
leaving that thousand dollars in your
emergency fund and hey if you want to
speed this process up i don't know what
your car is worth but is it worth
selling the car to get out of this mess
even faster
right i'm not positive i'll have to look
into i didn't look into that yet so i
will have a look at that some more if it
is
how much do you make a year
i make uh 43 000 a year
okay
yeah i mean this car is almost half of
your your yearly income and so i don't
know
how much you love it i'm i'm totally
okay with you keeping it because you're
about to pay this thing off but you know
me and john we drive crappy cars and
we're okay with it you know we like cars
but they're not our life and they're
depreciating assets so if you're not
going to be underwater on this car and
you can make
18 20 grand on it and then get something
to get you around well you can clean up
the student loan mess a whole lot
quicker
okay
all right does that sound good to you it
works for me all right john's happy
bianca is happy
everyone is happy and uh i'm excited for
bianca to become debt-free i know bianca
are you ready to do this it sounds like
you're kind of thinking about it
there's some hesitancy yeah what's the
hesitancy here there is a little
hesitancy because um
i'm usually i'm like a driver so um i
did have a car where i wasn't making
like anything it was my aunt's car and
then when that car went i opted to go
for a car that was a loaner car for my
dealership so i already had like 10
grand off it
and two i actually coach on the side as
well as a volunteer work so i'm usually
the one that drives around so i'd need
more of like a reliable car
isn't on the car
the hesitancy is
you love control
you save up all this money and then you
put it on a debt all at the same time
and what you're doing is you're trying
to have the best of both worlds which is
you're trying to run away from this lion
which is debt which is out of control
which is
a bank owning you a couple of banks
owning you right now
you're trying to get away from them very
gently and kindly and slowly and with
you still in charge and what i want you
to do is i want you to take every bit of
money you have except for that thousand
dollar emergency fund and pay off
something today
pay it off and then as you get paid next
month pay it off and if you get paid the
month after that pay it off because you
like the security of having this cash
it's like you're walking away from
you're a gazelle and you're walking away
from the lion and eventually it's going
to catch you right so just get this
stuff out of your life and it's going to
encourage you to work and get a second
job and a third job because it's going
to feel scary only having a thousand
bucks in there it's going to feel real
scary and it's supposed to it's not
supposed to be long-term but it is going
to propel you forward to get this crap
out of your life and stop hanging on to
your student loan because i love it and
it's cute and if you keep your car keep
your car great but get that sucker paid
off man yeah and bianca you said you're
a driver are you a professional driver
is this how you make your living
no it's not i'm just
when i go away to uh in coaching i'm
usually one of the drivers there so i'll
drive to
you know new york to
maryland to like every i will drive
everywhere because i need that i'm a
horrible taxi driver well i grew up in a
house where it was a very scary we got
to get new cars we got to get good
reliable cars but my 09 honda civic she
purrs john and she was six grand and
she'll take me anywhere i want to go in
my own toyota it is
still going we're going places still
going so bianca you can do this but
again like john's saying it's gonna have
to take a shift in your paradigm where
you decide i gotta let go some of this
control i'm gonna submit myself to a
proven plan that by the way millions of
people have done john because this is
the proven path to get to where i want
to go to get to wealth to get to where i
don't i'm not owned by lenders anymore
yeah and your income gets to stay with
you when you pay off that car debt you
know where that payment goes into your
pocket when you pay off those student
loans you know where that goes into your
pocket and now you can really start to
build the life where you are in control
instead of the illusion of control i
love it man that's what it's all about
well john this has been fun i'm having a
good time and i want to let people know
about your show because your show might
be the only show that's maybe an even
better time you have some fun on your
show you cover some serious topics but
you do it with levity so give us the
elevator pitch here if no one's
listening to the doctor john delaney
show what are they going to hear
man they're going to hear real calls
from real people it's very similar to
this show except instead of calling
about their debt they're calling about
their marriages and their parenting and
workplace challenges and their
communities and their mental health
and
just walking alongside folks who's the
wheels are coming off on the side or
they want to love people in their life
better
they want to
heal broken marriages they want to heal
their parent relationships they want to
talk through trauma they want to know
what to do next today on the show we
talked to some folks who
were just recovering from ida just
recovering from a tragic car accident
with somebody's family
and um so the stepbrother of one of the
13 servicemen that was killed and like
what do we do next right so um we get
into some hard and heavy topics and we
do it with with grace and with dignity
but we're in the in the messiness of
people's lives helping them figure out
what to do next yeah well hey go check
out the dr john deloney show podcast
youtube wherever you want to find it
ramsay solutions.com it's all there this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm george campbell host of the fine
print and entree leadership podcasts and
besides me is dr john deloney host of
the dr john deloney show give us a call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five talk about how unfair things are
you got a podcast called the fine print
yep and you host the entree leadership
podcast that's correct and we went
through about a thousand hours of
discovery to land on the john dalone
show well you know i try to be a little
more creative i i trust me i tried too
man george is the big winner you're
clearly more compelling than me because
it is what it is okay you can find all
of these shows on the ramsay network
along with the ramsey show the rachel
cruz show the ken coleman show see you
you're not you got a pattern i know
you're you're in good hands you're a
pattern breaker you're doing all right
all right it's open phones and we are
going to winston-salem north carolina to
talk to gary gary welcome to the ramsay
show
thank you quick question for you i have
saved up about ten thousand dollars
to take my wife in two and a half years
on a 30th anniversary
uh trip and i'm just wondering what can
i do with that money between now and
when i start planning the trip and
paying for the trip so
i can make a little bit more money on it
and maybe protect a little bit against
inflation if the prices start to go up
over the next couple years gary
back in middle school
were you the curvebuster
a few times were you the kid when
everyone got a c you got a 97 and the
teacher was like c
once once or twice yeah
i felt that i felt that man hey the
world needs more husbands like you who
are thinking ahead and saving thousands
and thousands and thousands of dollars
for an extraordinary trip a couple years
out good for you that's amazing really
incredible where are you planning on
going
uh wherever she wants i'm gonna leave
that oh my gosh you're killing me man
this is incredible gary if you were
single people would be lining up right
now funruther.com.net
gentlemen
let's all be gary way to go man wherever
she wants to go you're incredible i love
it okay so you have ten thousand dollars
in cash saved right now yes and when is
this trip happening
it will happen in
20
i think 24. sorry oh wow
kelly is literally texting her husband
right now to turn on the radio
wow men across america have not thought
about date night this month and he's
thinking about
a trip three years away that's
incredible well we're gonna do date
night in a few hours
gary stop talking you're this man is not
real this is a prank call john i'm
convinced i know it is okay well gary
here here's the short answer uh i don't
have a long one so i'm just gonna give
you the short one uh i would sock away
that money in a high-yield savings
account i use one i get about uh half a
percent maybe a little bit more than
that and it's not gonna be the sexiest
investment vehicle but what i don't want
is uh three years from now that ten
thousand dollars is four thousand
dollars because we have the next
pandemic right and the markets crashed
and now you can't go on the trip so i
want to keep that money safe um is that
the budget you guys have set or is this
kind of like hey it may be more than
this
well that was my goal of what to save up
so
i was saving a little bit each month
past
several you know seven or eight years so
and you're already at 10k wow
yeah
that's fantastic yeah i think the goal
here
i mean you can
this is gonna this is not gonna work out
mathematically this is more of a
psychological and a spiritual answer
here
you can make yourself absolutely bananas
by trying to match the
or
come out an eyelash ahead of the
fluctuating um
inflation rates or the
dude you're a planner you are such an
incredible extraordinary planner you are
one in a million brother and so i want
to take that burden from your soul put
that in a high-yield
savings account or a money market
account and
just let it let it be this has a this is
this is earmarked you've got this for a
very specific purpose
if you are running around and you want
to gamble on it you're going to be
gambling on hundreds of dollars not
thousands right you're going to be
gambling on
a couple hundred bucks here and it it's
just not worth the tax on your soul that
it would be to check it and move it and
mark man just you are so far ahead of
the game brother put that in an account
and let it roll off absolutely and you
know at a half a percent john he's
probably gonna make 50 bucks a year on
that money and that's okay it's 150
bucks that'll cover a nice dinner on on
one of those nights but he could save up
as much as he wants at this point he's
crushing it and we're giving gary a hard
time um
but this is what intentionality looks
like george relational intentionality
financial intentionality this is
somebody who said hey in 30 years i'm
going to want to take my life somewhere
special
i mean and we're 10 years out so why not
just reverse engineer that and put 30
bucks in an account and suddenly over
the next x number of years it's going to
pop up and it's going to be this much
money that's what intentionality looks
like and it's not hard right it's the
reverse is oh crap i haven't planned a
vacation for my wife uh we'll just swipe
the card
free credit cards and we'll try to
figure it out later right and then my
wife after we get on for this trip is
gonna have to get a third job to help us
pay this thing off right good for you
gary thanks for inspiring us and you'll
have fun on date night tonight i feel
convicted i need to plan a date night
right now john all right we're going to
brenda in tampa florida brenda welcome
to the ramsay show
hi guys thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can we help so um
i am considering selling my paid for
home
to
pay cash for another home that's worth
less use a difference to start a new
life
um
my but um my daughter's like really
emotionally attached to the house i am
too and it's
uh hard to know what to do because um
she's already been through so much and i
don't want to upset her by selling this
house but sometimes i feel like
it would be good to do that and then we
would be on like baby step seven instead
of basic three because the house was you
know
paid off just because it was cheap
moving a long time ago we still don't
even have a fully funded emergency fund
stuff like that what's wrong with your
current life why do you want to start a
new one
well
um
i have been kind of like delaying
endlessly
standing on the dotted line to get a
divorce because mostly because of
financial worries
so i feel like
that's keeping me there i struggle with
depression because of it and
um
you know i just i want to
i want to get rid of that financial
worry and then i feel like i'll be able
to take care of that
divorce and i feel confident to move
forward as a single mom instead of being
like oh i'm scared i'll stay married
because i'm i'm you know
you know financially secure that way
often the
financial situation is symptomatic of
the other challenges
and so i understand the i the order with
which you're trying to do things
but i would suggest you take a look at
and again you can do this how you want
to but i i'll take a suggest you look at
doing it in the reverse order so is this
if you if you sign on the dotted line
tomorrow and has somebody filed on you
is that what you're dealing with
no it was a mutual thing
and he doesn't have a claim to this
house
right
so he's come signed it over to you free
and clear
right
and what does a new life look like what
would it paint me a picture of your new
life
well
i was thinking of
um if if i did that it would have to
move a little farther away from like
some of my family and like we're in
tampa and there's if you go outside you
can get it to your house so i'd be
farther away from family but i was gonna
try to use the money to just kind of set
us up and then i could start to try to
go to school to try to get a better job
for something i'd actually love to do
and you know set up her college fund and
all that and just feel like confident to
you know just be a you know just me and
her and that i'm fully taking care of
everything and you know we could still
see our family but you know just kind of
try to start that lifestyle of so
building that future financially this
makes sense
i don't have a problem with this
financially here's the biggest challenge
though
when you get a new job and you get a new
home and you enroll in a new school
brenda's going to go with you
you're going to go with you
and if you're still hurting if you are
running from something
you'll get this new stuff and you'll get
all settled in and you'll still be
running
and so financially i i mean george you
can let you wait and i think it's a it's
a great idea i understand wanting to
wipe your hands of this home wipe your
hands of this
challenging marriage and be ready to
rock and roll into something new and
this course is going to be family
challenges and daughter all that's going
to be real there is no
simple move here but going is great but
i want you to make sure
you're talking to folks you've got
people in your corner you're talking to
a good therapist or pastor and you're
dealing with the trauma of this
transition too because brenda is gonna
go with brenda you go with you okay so
good luck and we'll be thinking about
you yeah this is not a financial
question jonas
relational stuff career stuff brenda's
got to get her life back and i think the
financial stuff will come with that
she's doing fine on that end
[Music]
[Music]
good folks we really value the input
from listeners of the ramsay show it
helps us know what's important to you so
we can deliver the right content that
will help you with the questions and
challenges you have right now the
current survey running we asked
listeners how much debt they've paid off
and you know what people have told us
they've paid off over 241
million dollars in debt so far so we
want to know how much debt you've paid
off along with a few other questions
about the show go to ramsaysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33789 it only
takes a few minutes it's not one of
those crazy surveys it takes you an hour
and a half just a few minutes and we've
increased the amount of the amazon gift
card to 250 bucks you'll be entered to
win it as a thank you for your time
there's no purchase necessary just text
survey to 33789 or visit
ramseysolutions.com
survey this is especially for you folks
who listen on the radio we've made it
easy to answer the survey on your phone
and we want to know
who do you like listening to who do you
don't like listening to
hashtag my kids need to go to school
guys i need to eat but i'm just saying
so a tech survey to 33789
or visit ramseysolutions.com
survey and you know john like we always
say if you have nothing nice to say just
leave it in the survey
you have nothing nice to say that's the
right place to talk about george that's
right it's great all right we've got
samuel on the line in lubbock texas
samuel welcome to the ramsay show
howdy john and greg um greg uh
george there you go guns up brother
what's up greg sounds like a nice guy
great take it
we like george what's up sam
okay so me and my wife are in baby step
two right now
and her father passed away last friday
oh gosh samuel i'm so sorry brother
so
she had asked me about
purchase of me and her purchasing
the
tombstone
for
for her father and potentially like do a
companion one i'm thinking
with uh for
when the mother passes later on
uh because they have their their plots
together
so i
i know what she wants and
but i'm kind of torn between
uh
the right decision to make
because i know
it's like we we should be staying on a
baby step but at the same time it's
it's very emotional for her and
i i don't know
what's i just need some help and
guidance of
what what would be a wise decision well
first man our hearts with you and your
family and our prayers with you and your
family and it's a hard hard season
um and
i just
let's just be honest this is a hard
phone call for you to make and i know
that because you're supposed to have all
the right answers and you're supposed to
be able to
help your wife walk through this and it
takes a lot of courage to reach out and
say hey i'm kind of in a rock and a hard
place
and depending on who you ask you're
going to get a
bunch of definitive answers either way
right so i appreciate the call man um
yeah
and george feel free to weigh in on this
my thought here is this man my thought
is you pause baby step two and you go to
one of the local dealers there in
lubbock and you do this the right way
don't go into debt for this but do this
the right way i don't think you need to
buy the companion one right now
um
is she in is is your mother-in-law in
bad health and she about to pass away
here soon
i i don't believe so okay yeah i i think
you handle each one of these challenges
as they pop up um that's why you've got
your thousand dollar
emergency fund there at the beginning
pause baby step two this is one of those
moments right that you need to honor
your wife you need to honor your
father-in-law you need to honor this
moment and of course man you want to
stay on on the baby steps and all that
but this is this is a legacy moment this
is a big deal moment this is when you
just hit pause and get the funeral taken
care of get the
the
the tombstone taken care of um and this
is again what your emergency fund is for
and then you're gonna resume this stuff
when it resumed the baby steps when it's
over yeah absolutely we tell people to
pause baby step two in storm or stork
mode so if there's a baby on the way or
you're weathering a storm like you guys
are right now it's totally okay to pause
i don't want you to feel bad about this
i know that you were excited to get rid
of this debt uh but right now you get to
get off the horse and and honor this
man's life and i want you to do it the
smart way i don't want you to make
emotional decisions with your money
right now and just throw money at this i
want you to do your research like john's
talking about call around
try to get the best price possible and
don't overdo it like john's saying you
can wait on the companion headstone and
you can just do what you need to do
right now to honor his life that's what
it's all about not about how much you're
going to spend on the funeral yeah and
can i tell you this brother um
be with your wife on this one this isn't
the time to sit down and
um
uh
let her know that you're right
and that you've got this you know i mean
there's a right way to do this and
obviously don't don't go into debt and
don't be obnoxious and don't emotionally
spend but also honor your wife here okay
exactly i understand yeah hit pause here
brother do it with joy in your heart and
with the grief in your heart right um
and when i say joy in your heart knowing
that you can take care of this you got
that thousand dollar emergency fund
that's what it's for
of course you can be disappointed you
can be frustrated um but you're gonna
this is the right moment i like that
i've never heard that storm in stork
mode but this is a storm man this is
what this this what this plan is for for
these moments and you got it yeah thanks
for the call samuel
all right we're moving on to lacey in
kansas city missouri lacey welcome to
the ramsay show
hi how are you guys doing great how can
we help
okay well here's my question
my husband and i do not have any debt we
have each have a roth ira we are
self-employed
but we have 120 000 in savings and we
don't know where to put the money
to where it's earning us more than just
a half a percent
that's a good problem to have so you
guys are completely debt free you have a
fully funded emergency fund and are you
investing 15 percent of your household
income into retirement accounts
well we each have a roth ira that we max
out
pretty much every year that we started
in 2018 and we've maxed out most every
year okay so you're saying hey we've
maxed out the roth ira what are the
other options for investing because we
don't have a 401k because you said
you're self-employed
yes
okay yeah that's great with 120 000 you
guys are in a really good financial
position there are other things that you
could max out like your hsa that can be
a great retirement vehicle
and dave was just talking about this the
other day he maxes out his hsa and he
leaves it and he pays his health
expenses just from his own bank account
because that hsa is a great tax-free uh
vehicle for you guys to sock away money
and you can actually do investments in
your hsa if you've got one over there so
i'm not sure about your situation on
that side what are your other financial
goals are the things that you guys are
wanting to do
well originally we wanted to build a
house but after everything went crazy
the past year and materials are high we
decided because we wanted to um just pay
for that right not have to take out a
loan but we can't really do that right
now
wait hold on lacey
slow the roll here are you talking about
being patient and diligent and
accountable with the money you have stop
the madness who are you
you guys are incredible six in my
husband's thirties so we
oh my gosh wow the world needs more
lacy's in it yeah lacy's and gary's
that's what we learned today well uh
lacey here's my thing there are some
other investment options for you guys
but it sounds like the next big goal is
a house am i hearing that right
yeah if it can be affordable
well you don't want to go into debt yeah
you're saying you want to do with cash
you're saying i don't even want to take
out a mortgage
yeah
okay well this is this is very
impressive john
you know if you have a longer horizon i
mean you could take some of this money
and put it away in good mutual funds or
index funds and a brokerage account
meaning it's not in a retirement account
this is money that you guys could use
five years from now so you may you know
this is something that uh is a very wise
decision it's to sock away 50 grand a
year into this brokerage account uh to
where five years from now is growing
it's giving you maybe 10
rate of return and now you've got a big
pile of money to pay for a house in cash
when do you think you guys are gonna
have enough money to buy this house
well we already have um we already have
a house that's paid for currently so we
just build on our property because we
have a few acres lacey who are you
uh is this a prank call i feel like yeah
your pranking is here this is incredible
yeah i think i think what georgia said
man roll the money into a brokerage
account and a mutual fund let it sit and
y'all y'all aren't in any rush to do
anything which is remarkable and it also
gets that money out of this is how money
happens to end up in a boat fund or in a
you know we need we need an rv fund
right it ends up in these other places
uh well actually go buy an rv you got to
pay for a house but yeah park it in the
brokerage account and let it sit
that's amazing lacey you guys are
crushing it and we're rooting for you i
want you to focus on your your closer
long-term goals because you guys
truthfully you're going to be
multi-millionaires so i'm not as worried
as the investing part right now i want
you guys to get in the house because i
could hear your voice you want to do it
and you want to do it with no debt which
is absolutely incredible hey john it's
been a fun hour we'll be back with you
guys before you know it this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm george campbell host of the
fine print podcast and the entree
leadership podcast and i'm joined today
by my very good friend ramsey
personality dr john deloney that's not
what you were saying off air that i was
your very good friend well on air not
fair you know i've got to be kinder in
front of all the people well i'm glad
glad that i've moved up in the world and
become your favorite moving on up we'll
hang out one day john we're having a
good time here the phone call is free
absolutely free and the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
mia joins us from sacramento california
mia welcome to the ramsay show
hi human um my question today is two
parts but the first part is um i have
paid off all my debt except one bit um
way to go about five thousand dollars
thank you
um and um
i just
so it was five thousand so i had to save
for that amount of money
so what i did was i saved and i just
kept saving so i saved 20 000
so um but i just can't pull the trigger
and pay it off i i just i don't know so
it's like you were running a marathon
and you went past the finish line and
you were like i'm just going to keep
going
no it's not i don't think it's out no
you got to the sign that says yeah you
got to the sign mia that said last mile
and everyone starts cheering and you
just
cracked open a beer and sat down and
you're like i'm good
it's going to sit here for a while
yeah so i'm like stuck in step two if i
do this i'll be in step four because
there's twenty thousand dollars so you
already saved your phone oh my emergency
fund okay so tell us about this debt
yeah what is it beautiful is it cute
is it sentimental do you love it
no it's a repossession of a car that
happened 2017.
and
i'm just like and is that a look it's
with an attorney now
um because there's a judgment against me
i don't know if i'm scared to call the
attorney like i have the number i dialed
the number and i hung up i won't because
it's a voicemail it goes straightly to a
voicemail
um and you're supposed to leave your
number do you have a judge do you have a
judgment payoff letter in your hand
um yeah i have the court documents where
it was the the judge
granted the um
you know the order for me to pay and
this was in 2017.
um
are you afraid that that bill has
tripled or quadrupled on you because you
haven't paid it
well it started off at 2300 so i'm
guesstimating it's about five right now
so you don't even know i added the
injury so you're in la la you got your
hands over your ears going i don't want
to know i don't want to know exactly
yeah well i'm thinking it's about i've
done the math so it's about between five
and six thousand dollars and you hope
you hope so mia what do you do for a
living
i'm a government worker for the state
that's another part of my question but
okay so how much about 67. how much data
how much debt have you paid off
um oh i've paid off
22 000 so this is the left but all of it
was smaller it was credit card debt
are you are you you sound like you are
brilliant are you smart
i i'm yeah i'm just saying yeah
are you like are you a hard worker
very
are you a person of integrity and
character
yes very important to me would you would
you date somebody that was like you
absolutely
so you're checking every box you're
brilliant you're smart you're a hard
worker you're a person a character
and yet
i just love my debt
you have marked every box
you are the kind of person we want in
our communities you want this kind of
people out there leading things right
and so here's what i want you to do i
want you to trust mia as much as we do
i want you to think of mia as highly as
we do
mia you are worthy of being
free
you have solved for freedom
and the last thing is that last little
chain link is in those hedge clippers
and you just gotta
pull them
okay okay just gotta do it what why are
you scared of freedom
i'm just thinking and i think about
because i listen to you i think i might
be catastrophizing like i'm like what if
i lose my job and then i'll go wrong in
this 20 000 i got rid of five and and
then you know how i'm gonna take care of
me and my son and then you know it could
all fall down and i gave him five
thousand when i could have really held
on to it oh well
or or
you have 15 000 in your fully funded
emergency fund you have no lawyers
breathing down your neck no ticker
running in the background that's adding
up more interest and more interest and
more interest and then you are free
you're
free and you're a hard worker you'll
have 5 000 more dollars in a couple more
months right
and then you and your son can do
whatever you want to like hey what's
your what's your favorite food mia
uh thai food here's what i want you to
do i want you to make that call today as
soon as you're off the line and keep
calling until someone picks up and i
want you to get this debt out of your
life this week and i want you to go get
some thai food with your kid and have
the night of your life celebrating the
fact that you don't have payments
anymore
how great would that feel okay
that would be awesome like i really so
can i ask you guys i want to ask the
second question really quick come on um
i'm 43 i have about 4k i just started
retirement
and
um i want to know is it possible hope
for me to have a home i have really
affordable rent right now but i've told
myself either it's a home or it's
retirement because i've waited so late
to start building my retirement never
too late you're so young you said 43
honey you're just getting started you
are just getting started
never too late you can do both of these
things and at this rate with no payments
in the world and your income which is
only going to go up because you're
brilliant
you can do both you can get in a house
and our parameters just so you know i
want you to put i think you can put 20
or more down you can do this with a
15-year fixed rate mortgage to where
this thing's gone before you retire and
i guarantee you're going to do it
earlier because you hustle
and i want you to do it to where the
payment is no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay
and you're going to invest 15
into retirement accounts and in 25 years
you're going to be a multi-millionaire
with a paid for house now buying a house
in sacramento that may be a taller order
than buying one in st louis missouri
right and so yeah you may be staring at
the local sacramento housing prizes and
thinking
i might not be able to do this and it
may be that down the road you think i
may take my
brilliance and my character and my hard
work and my debt-free life to another
state to another city um that's all very
real right so somebody's going to be
dependent on my cost of living where
you're living right but don't box
yourself into
don't become free and then box yourself
into unfree thinking
i'm free
no i'm just back to the no
you got nobody chasing you anymore and
now it's a matter of where do i want to
be what kind of life do i want to build
i would love to live here but i can't
own a home here so i'm going to move
there right or i would love to keep
working here but i can make double the
salary over here now you are
it's a great reminder in addition to
going to thai food i want you to look
yourself in the mirror
the day after you pay this thing off and
remind yourself
i'm brilliant i'm a hard worker i'm a
person of character and i deserve
freedom and now sky's the limit because
i have unhooked the last chain
around my
neck i'm free i'm inspired john you can
take back control you can do it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switched to puretalk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just thirty
dollars a month get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined by ramsay
personality dr john deloney this is the
ramsey show if you haven't heard kristy
wright national bestselling author and
ramsey personality has been heads down
on a project she's been passionate about
for a long time because it deals with an
issue that's affected her personally how
to feel balanced in your life and the
pre-sale of her new book take back your
time the guilt-free guide to life
balance is almost over
this book was born out of christy's real
life struggles for years she was running
on empty and was stretched way too thin
and as a mom of three she realized
something had to change
she took a long hard look at her life
and figured out why she felt overwhelmed
and she discovered that balance is about
doing the right things at the right time
and you get to decide what's right for
you this is not some productivity book
or a book on just saying no you're going
to learn the step-by-step plan on how to
be intentional with your time and how to
finally prioritize the things you really
want to do so they stop getting pushed
to the back burner time is like your
money if you're not intentional with it
it's gonna leave
so september 13th is the last day to
pre-order and i want you to pre-order so
that you can get over 50 bucks in free
gifts that come along with this
including the audiobook the e-book a
ticket to her live stream go to the
online store at ramseysolutions.com and
pre-order your copy of take back your
time today for just 20 bucks and you're
gonna get over 50 in free bonus items
all right jonathan joins us in kansas
city jonathan welcome to the ramsay show
hi how are you guys doing today doing
great how can we help
yes sir i was calling because
four-year marriage seven-year
relationship
kids are involved but i am not about a
lot of biological leader kids
and we are in the process of getting a
divorce
and i
can't really i don't know how to
handle everything because of how it all
happened
um so walk me through what happened man
um
everything was good what you would call
the honeymoon phase
like i said none of the kids were mine
stepped in
got real good with the kids and
got married then fell off a lot of
things i didn't know i didn't grow up in
the household of marriage so
being 24 and married to a 34 year old
who's already experienced there was a
lot of things that i needed to learn a
lot of bad things that happened between
both of us
wife went out of town she kept going
back out of town and
once we finally decided on a divorce i
found out she was actually engaged to
another man
so sorry man that's heartbreaking
brother i'm so sorry
um so
give me your specific question brother
how can i help
[Music]
i take in trying to
get my life back the reason why i'm
asking is because
one of the children is back with me with
an agreement from their father to finish
his last year in high school so he could
still play sports
but it's i'm it's kind of hard for me to
let everything go and i really don't
know how to push forward right now how
old are you man
i am 31 now
so jonathan
i first want to applaud you
because
what our culture has taught
heartbroken
frustrated angry men to do
is to
get angry
grip the wheel even tighter
and get loud and puff our chest up and
run off to the next thing
and the fact that you're
being patient taking this thing slow and
you're reaching out saying hey i don't
know what next step to take tells me
that you're wise and you are strong
beyond your wildest imagination
so good for you okay
i appreciate that um
right now
when did she file on you
um
to tell you the truth i don't see i just
went to visit a lawyer and i
don't see anything on there that says
that i've had the divorce vows against
me we kind of argued because
at first i told her i would pay for it
but then i didn't pay for it because i
really didn't want to get the divorce
when's the last time you all sat down
just the two of you no lawyers no people
no kids and just looked at each other
and said
where are we
i haven't seen her since around march
the 12th wow and
yeah she was only here she missed my
anniversary
came back the weekend uh it came back
the weekend of our anniversary after she
missed the flight stayed a little bit
after mother's day and left again and
that was the last time i saw her when's
the last time you all talked to each
other not through text message but on
the telephone
last time i talked to her was probably
a couple of weeks ago when
one of the kids was playing a joke and
said that the dog was already gone
and she called me and asked what
happened to the dog and i told her that
i didn't have anything to do with it
because they were the ones who were
doing it but we haven't had a big
conversation with each other
for a while okay
so i'm gonna give you the pie in the sky
answer and then i'm gonna give you the
possible reality answer okay
pie in the sky answer is
two people who are adults
who've got kids in the mix who have
a the kids biological father still in
the mix
two adults need to sit down and have an
adult interaction
even if that adult interaction is this
marriage is over and here's what we're
gonna do next
um but just you i mean you can ghost
somebody when you're dating them in
middle school you can go somebody in
high school and just stop returning
texts when you're married to them or
you've got kids you can't do that you
got to be an adult now i understand that
adults act like children all the time we
wouldn't have a show if they didn't
right
so the other side of that is
you're gonna have to make some hard
decisions about moving forward
is this marriage over that's what i'm
asking you
yes it is okay so at some point somebody
has to
do the hard thing
but the next step and go get this
cleaned up with the attorneys involved
and then make some hard decisions about
these children
and this isn't you're going to have to
be able to separate i'm angry i'm
frustrated i'm heartbroken i love this
woman i gave this woman my 20s i gave
these kids i was there and she stepped
out on me you're going to have to put
that in one spot and you're gonna have
to do what's right for these kids
and you're gonna have to grieve
you're gonna have to give yourself
permission to be heartbroken for a
season that means getting with another
a group group of guys that are around
your age a little bit older than your
age and sit down and be able to say
this sucks
like i i i feel like i'm underwater some
days i feel like i don't want to eat
some days i feel like i can't get out of
bed some days you're going to have to
let that process take its take it's take
its toll right and some days it's going
to feel like you can't get out of bed
some days it's going to feel like man
that wave just hit me and i'm going to
drown you're not you're not you're not
you're not
but you're going to have to let that
process happen otherwise you're going to
race out you're going to find somebody
else you're going to get another job
you're going to move you're going to
flex you can do all those things
and that grief is going to stay in there
and it's going to come out in all kinds
of bonkers ways
in in counseling we used to say it's
it's a leakage issue you can deal with
it or it will find its way out and it
usually comes out at real inopportune
times okay and you sound like someone
who is so wise and so strong
who knows man i gotta just deal with
this right and so i want you to do two
things i want you to get some a group of
guys in your life and if you don't have
them i want you to find them whether
that's uh um some friends you've got
some co-workers that you trust whether
you've got a local pastor whether you
need to reach out to a counselor you got
to sit down and tell somebody face to
face i'm heartbroken a woman broke my
heart
and then you're gonna have to go sit
down with an attorney i would reach out
to her one more time and say can we talk
like adults on how we're gonna end this
marriage you've clearly stepped out
you've moved on we need to go through
the mechanical un detangling process
that's not even a word but how are we
going to untangle this our finances our
stuff the kids all that stuff
and if she says no i don't want to talk
to you i'm out then you're gonna have to
go see a lawyer and you're gonna have to
go through the x's and o's yourself and
then you gotta make a plan and then
you're gonna move on right
yeah and jonathan one last thing here i
want you to advocate for yourself
because you've been hosed emotionally
and relationally i don't want you to get
hosed financially on top of all of that
so make sure that you're protecting
yourself too because
a divorce turns a marriage into a
business transaction and that's
unfortunately where we find ourselves
and you seem like a such a big-hearted
sweet guy you want to be a good father
figure for these kids you want to do the
right things and that means advocating
for yourself and doing the things that
john is talking about i'm so sorry going
through this man it's really
heartbreaking jonathan
listen um when we go through hard
relational heartbreak the the temptation
is to withdraw
feels right man but that's the worst
thing you can do you got to make sure
you've got people in your corner reach
out to somebody today brother
so great to talk to you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsay solutions on the
debt-free stage it's dwayne and jenny
how you guys doing doing great great
where you from
thief river falls minnesota yep that
sounds nice what's the nearest big city
over there probably fargo about two
hours southwest okay i'm hearing a
little the accent it makes me happy very
peaceful so how much debt have you guys
paid off
you want to say it yeah uh about 59
600 and about four dollars just
interesting about 60. about here and
there right
to the penny congratulations guys thank
you amazing how long did this take about
three and a half years wow okay and what
was your range of income during that
time it went from about 66 000
uh up to about 77 back down to about 66
so yeah all right was there some side
work involved there what was going on
yeah she had a photography business and
i switched jobs multiple times got laid
off lost jobs just kept at it man wow
that's awesome what do you guys do for a
living
i work at digi-key electronics customer
service uh i work in a cnc milling
operation so very cool all right you
were going to say a cnc music factory
and we're going to start singing right
there you go milling factory is good so
this 59 thousand dollars what kind of
debt was this it was most of mine um
two credit cards student loans a car
loan
and then he had a car loan
irs and a lawyer
yeah a little bit of everything
i arrested a lawyer just a debt party
was going on
yeah so so what happened
three and a half years ago that you just
guys woke up and said no more well um it
actually started about a year before
um i was going down to the minnesota
state fair with my aunt
and um
i talked to her about
how i couldn't pay cash for just a 10
meal i had to put on a credit card
and um she mentioned that there's this
guy
that teaches people how to get out of
debt
and they do the snowball method and she
was explaining it to me and i kind of
thought it was kind of dumb and just
kind of brush it off and
went on my way and then
about a month later i kind of
sat down and thought about it wrote down
my list of debts and
bought the total money makeover book
didn't finish it but
but i started um fpu uh later in the
january after meeting dwayne
and then we kind of started off the
debt-free journey art together right wow
and how did that conversation go when
she sat down and looked at you dwayne
and said if you're if you're going to be
with me
we ride with d ramsey man it was uh
actually was real welcoming because
before i even knew about dave i had been
doing budgeting very similar which i was
surprised by very similar to what he
teaches she came to me and one day and
said hey um you know i kind of got this
down but i see you're doing really well
you know it's well you know before we
were engaged and she's like can you help
me with this
so we just teamed up and you know got it
done and man we battled we got through
so many different obstacles it was a
battle murphy definitely
lived in our house
kicked sally what were some of those
things that hit you guys where you're
like oh gosh this again
what you want me to take it yeah
all right so uh she switched jobs one
time to a far better employer better
benefits better pay it was just an
all-around better company
me on the other hand i ran into a lot of
struggles
no joke uh
bounced around from job to job from
losing jobs or getting laid off and uh
one company went bankrupt
just never ever stopped man we uh
had house problems because we bought a
house that's like almost 90 years old um
you know after we paid off the debt the
roof would need to replace things so it
was just like man we just we could not
catch a break uh had we not had all the
problems we had we would have had it
paid off year and a half earlier but we
just did not stop even being unemployed
four or five months for me we just
stockpiled all that cash until we could
get out once we got out you know we just
we're glad we saved everything because
the roof went so
yeah
wow hey yeah
do you recognize what you've done
yeah well we for for both of us you know
we started this journey i know for me it
was about just trying to get out of the
hole to build wealth the longer we've
been on this journey for me it's about
leaving a legacy behind what kind of
legacy can i leave behind for her you
know if i go before her and if we have
kids what kind of legacy can we leave
for them so it's like when her and i you
know move on to you know the next life
we have children
that are going to have
huge potential in front of them that we
didn't have at that point so yeah but
you guys you found something out about
dwayne
and that's that dwayne is gonna i'm
looking at you dwayne
you found out stuff about dwayne which
is dwayne didn't quit
and dwayne keeps going and the two of
you found out that your relationship is
stronger when y'all are together and
y'all are walking on the same road arm
and arm step by step and you can get it
done come with me
nobody's getting between us and look at
you guys you kept going and you kept
getting up and you kept pulling each
other up and one of you get knocked down
and get knocked down hard and you pick
each other up and here you are man you
are a testament it's it's
it it sounds cool if you make half a
million dollars right and you pay it off
in four months it's tough when you keep
getting laid off and fired and then cove
it and then up and then down then the
roof and you guys stayed after it you
stayed after it
you are heroes not wearing capes and i'm
i'm proud to know you it's incredible
guys i mean yeah it was you know it was
just a heck of a journey we've had
people come up to us even on the airport
yesterday you know we had a guy come up
to us he said i know what show you're
going on
how did he know uh we just well we could
tell he's from the midwest like we are
how do you tell someone's from the
midwest this is a whole another like he
said the accent you know okay you can
pick it up sure and uh he's he's like
what do you guys you know what's the
trip for we told him like oh cool you
going on there i said yes we are that's
incredible he's like oh i met a couple
celebrities
so what would you guys say the key is to
getting out of debt
um sticking together um
i'm the free spirit he's the
money guy and um
it was a lot of no's and a lot of maybe
laters but
it's just sticking to the budget and
sticking together and just seeing the
end goal was a really big part for me
yeah have you guys ever been debt-free
in your adult life
no but he has been i was debt-free
before i met her
and then uh and then he bought a car
then i i went stupid so
you got to forgot to pay old uncle sam
right yeah yeah yeah don't don't do that
anymore yeah there you go well you guys
cleaned up a whole big mess and you
fought and fought and scraped and clawed
to get to where you are today how does
it feel to be debt-free
it feels amazing yeah it's definitely
like a weight lifted off your shoulders
has the as the check cleared where you
had no bills
uh yeah we've had that and you've got to
feel what it looks like to think what's
all that much
where does it go yeah well yeah we were
we've i mean just even having our family
members
they're just like wow you guys did
something really amazing that's
incredible you know i've gotten comments
from people halfway across the world
that have commented me and just been
like man wow that's pretty incredible so
good for you guys you guys are an
impressive bunch we're so honored to
have you here today we've got a copy of
the legacy journey for you that is
absolutely the next chapter in your
story as you now build wealth and and
give generously and outrageously for the
rest of your life we also have a copy of
the total money makeover that you can
give to someone else so they can say
this is dumb and they go wait actually
this this might work i might try this
out so we have we have a copy of both of
those books for you and we are just
honored to have you here today
congratulations on debt freedom
appreciate it thank you you ready for
this yes yes the moment we've all been
waiting for john let's do this it's
dwayne and jenny from fargo north dakota
area they paid off 59 000 and some
change in three and a half years making
66 up to 77 back to 66 and now they're
here to do a debt free screen count it
down
three
two
one we're dead friends
dwayne and jenny
they brought the power on that one john
they're not fooling around oh now
they're hugging that's so amazing i love
the hand in hand it gets me every time
when the interlocking hand on the
debt-free scream there is just like
nothing's gonna stop these people apart
george there's man
i say this every time it's my favorite
part of the show is to get to
take the theories and the hypotheses and
the the math problem out and see two
people who said six months ago two years
ago three and a half years ago
put a stake in the ground and we're
never doing this again let's change
everything and they fall down they
scrape their knees they get hit in their
head they get punched in the mouth they
keep going they keep going they keep
going and they show up here
accomplishing a goal together saying
never again and their grandkids aren't
going to know the struggles that they
endured because they said no
more
it's crazy it's amazing what the human
spirit can do when it realizes this job
for this you take control
and you can do america you can become
debt free and scream on that stage just
like blaine and jay congratulations guys
this is the random show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
habakkuk 319 the sovereign lord is my
strength he makes me as sure-footed as a
deer able to tread upon the heights
christopher reeve said so many of our
dreams at first seem impossible then
they will seem improbable and then when
we summon the will they soon become
inevitable
love that open phones this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
ethan joins us in phoenix arizona ethan
welcome to the ramsay show
hi how's it going great how can we help
today
good i'm so glad you guys took my calls
it's crazy that i mean [ __ ] you guys
so i decided to tell you um
i'm calling because i'm getting married
in two months
congrats brother awesome yeah
thank you thank you thank you and my
i guess you can say girlfriend's
father-in-law he has a little bit of
trouble with the money and it makes me
really sad because he makes
pretty good money for
being
i he makes good money and whatever but
i just wanted to know like boundary wise
and
um what's where's my standpoint like how
can i help him
being his son-in-law help him with his
money like do i say something or
what do you guys think never under any
circumstances ever
not your circus not your monkey not your
job
your job is to take care of your wife to
love her to co-create an incredible home
and financial legacy and
create a remarkable household that's
going to be make you good neighbors and
good community members and good citizens
and
good church members whatever you're all
going to do with your life but your
father-in-law's life is your
father-in-law's life
if he ever takes you out for breakfast
one day and says hey man tell me about
the
this way you guys are doing this great
um but no it's not your job man
the best thing you can do is live your
life publicly
in such a way where he's like whoa you
guys did what you can pay cash for cars
yeah how did you do that that's the only
way he's going to take any advice from
you
okay you're about to say something what
were you gonna say
the reason i ask is because he is going
through like a divorce in his life he
married someone who was
keeping on the books but um
i i'm expecting the question to come up
pretty soon because
recently in my adult life he's seen the
way that i treat money in the way that i
save up and stuff and
we're really open with money but to him
so he sees the way that we
you know
live our lives of money i sense a
question or a concern from him coming
soon about how he can do the same thing
because
he
talks all the time about how he
never has enough money or he
he just lives paycheck to paycheck and
whatnot so i was just wondering when the
question does come from him i would
never really just be like hey you got to
do this money i was more
wanting to know when the question arises
from him
what can i say or whatever
for a wedding present ethan we're going
to send you a copy of total money
makeover and i want you just to hold it
and if that question ever comes up
i want you to tell your father-in-law
read this book
and if you have questions after this
book you and i will go grab coffee and
you can look at him and smile and say
you're paying
and
i'll talk to you about how we do this
and for sure let
um let the book it's a step-by-step
process and we're going to give it to
you for a wedding gift
and let that book be the entry point
because what you don't want to do
is create a well i know what you should
be doing with your father-in-law he's
already gonna have enough problems with
you man you're marrying his daughter for
crying out loud so yeah keep the peace
it sounds like you're anticipating
something because you want him to ask
you
and you have the what you think is the
right answer and you can't wait to give
it to him and what i want to tell you
brother let that go
his money is the way he's chosen to
handle his money that's it that's his
circus man
and as guide a guy as um
husband to almost husband to
about to be new family members he sits
down and says hey let's talk hand him
that book and say we'll we'll follow up
later but man stay out of that business
man because you're
like like george said
you do you proselytize to the world by
how you live your life right that's
going to be the the loudest most
beautiful way you can communicate this
message absolutely and i think one once
it is solicited it's a different
conversation you can do that with grace
you've been invited in right yeah and
you're not going to do with judgment i
can hear it in your voice that you
really do want to help him and so i
think once that day comes absolutely
grab coffee and show them how you did it
that's it and you don't have to say
you're you're doing terrible financially
and i can help you're just showing him
the tools that you used as well i just
can't i'm trying to just imagine if i'd
called my father-in-law a week after my
after my honeymoon and been like hey
all right so here's a couple of things
you're doing wrong with your money and
that wouldn't have gone well yeah it's
so hard with family
yeah you want them to win you want to
love them yeah um and
that's not your circus yep yeah all
right we're moving on to larry in long
beach california
larry welcome to the ramsay show
yeah hi how are you doing great how can
we help you i have a
yeah i said there i got a question i'm
sitting here i've got a low interest
loan three percent and i've got about 15
or 16 payments left
and i also have the money in my savings
account right now
that you know i'm getting next to
nothing for the interest
and so i thought about taking the money
and just transferring over paying off
the mortgage
um but that means i would go from
basically my emergency funds from six
months down to three months
so i was calling to see what you guys
would say okay so you've got a
mortgage that you're only debt is that
correct
yeah yes i have no other debt and you're
wondering if you can about 24 000 on it
24 000. okay uh yeah what is your
financial situation outside of that your
income stable do you have a spouse yeah
my and yeah my income stable
i make about 120 a year
and i've got about 57 um thousand in the
bank right now
hey larry so it's like okay yes
congratulations you'll be debt free by
the end of the day
oh cool
this is incredible this is a great spot
to be how much is left on the mortgage
yeah 24 000. uh yeah 24 200 and change
and you've got 57 in your emergency fund
so you're cutting in half down to three
months but guess what your expenses just
got lower didn't they
exactly that's right so you're going to
push this back to six months i was
talking to my wife about it and she says
okay let's see what dave would say ah
well we'll be dave's proxy and he would
say the same thing he is way better
looking and he's done this a lot longer
but if you're gonna hang on to that
three-month emergency fund man you're
gonna be debt-free by the end of the day
write them a check and then you all go
out to dinner and celebrate tonight
because you you good folks are
officially debt-free house and
everything this is huge i'm excited for
you guys do you feel it yet yeah thank
you
yeah i mean i'm in that spot right now
that i'm like yeah go either way but
yeah we've been leaning that way in fact
last night i had the bank on the phone
oh my gosh okay what's my payout balance
you know yeah and so they told me
yeah and so we have everything set up
for the 8th of october
and they go now if you stick with that
then fine you follow through and i'm
like okay fine because i already made
the september payment
so i'm okay with a little bit a few more
days but
yeah basically i know what i need to do
what is this house worth
um i would say 750 to 800.
whoo oh my gosh are we talking to a
millionaire now larry
yes
brother congratulations
california
people can't pay off their homes in
california it's impossible it's never
been done you can't pay off your house
in california and have an emergency fund
and listen so you're going to take your
120 000 you're going to pay this off in
what in
four months you're going to have this
emergency fund back up right
right and you're going to have a fully
funded emergency fund you're going to
have a million dollars plus
in
what's your retirement what are you
getting retirement accounts
well i have two retirements coming in
one from a company i've been with for 25
years and another for a little over five
plus the money i stuck on the side so
i've got 401ks in a couple different
locations
what's the amount right right currently
right now i'm at about 750 000. larry
let's go larry congratulations man
babysitter congratulations just like
that larry i just want as we close the
show out what advice would you give
inspiration would you give to another
guy out there who may be wanting to be
where you are
it just needs to be a priority i mean
i've kind of set myself there i thought
i've
uh knew about dave for a long time i've
listened to him forever
um i took his classes
and you you knew about him you took his
classes and he did it and you did it
with priorities and attentionality way
to go larry i love it that puts this
hour of the show in the books i want to
thank producer james childs associate
producer kelly daniel
spend wisely save intentionally give
outrageously
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
you